welcome back to peterborough center the
british government has rejected claims
that shin feins election victory in
northern ireland could lead to the
breakup of the uk despite the party's
push a referendum on a united ireland
prime minister boris johnson is now
threatening to tear up post-brexit
trading arrangements with the eu despite
warnings from american president biden
that it could undermine the good friday
agreements are we edging ever closer to
a united ireland and a disunited united
kingdom i'm joined by someone who i'm
sure will have a strong view about this
the former irish prime minister and one
of the founding fathers of the good
friday agreement bertie hermes thank you
so much for joining me
how are you doing person very well i'm
going to say i'm i'm sort of twitchy
about what is going on politically with
the united kingdom with ireland with all
of it actually and i've been like this
since brexit and we've severed our way
from the european union it feels like a
lot of things have are being splinted do
you think we're going to see
a united island
looming or certainly a referendum on it
in the next few years and if we do
could this signal the beginning of the
end of the uk
well i think there are a number of
problems at the moment um
the elections last week were fairly good
i mean there were peaceful elections uh
most of the
political debate was on bread and butter
economic issues um except maybe for one
party the protocol was pushed a fair
loss but um there wasn't much about the
border pole or united ireland new
ireland shared ireland for different
names but people put on it so it wasn't
a big issue in the election and i
suppose
it is into good friday agreements that
from time to time there can be a
referendum and my view is that until the
preparatory work is done of how it would
look what it would cost how it would
evolve and that is not a good idea to
have it and i think most people are of
that view so it will there will be a
vote at some stage but the it's early
stages before the work is done but
unfortunately
that has moved away from the issue a
little bit what happens now
um is that brexit is back into the game
again and the northern ireland protocol
which was part of the withdrawal
agreement that prime minister boris used
to say brexit was done
that
now the british government through the
attorney general through various
ministers are saying that they might
unilaterally
bring in legislation to amend that that
has created i think great friction on
the whole island of ireland uh the
government here are uh really upset
about it i think our american colleagues
are very upset about it uh president
biden is but well it's a betrayal
it's a betrayal of the agreement and the
bottom line with all this is that when
brexit was getting done as boris johnson
kept telling us nobody had worked out
what to do about the border situation
and that has never been properly
resolved and that's why he's trying to
reopen it now because he knows he didn't
have a plan for it and it's not worked
in any way that suits anybody and that
seems to me the fundamental problem
right from the start they never sorted
this before during or after brexit
well we're still i think um
very study even after brexit when the
debate took place under withdrawal
agreement and
not to make sure we've no land border uh
on the island of ireland uh boris
johnson negotiated with the irish
government and with the european union
uh that protocol and and within a few
months of them negotiating it he said
that he didn't like it and it it was it
was a bad idea but he was the one who
negotiated it but right you know i think
what i'd like to say first is that this
thing is negotiated and sorted out in a
namical way if the british government go
down the road
of arbitrarily and breaking the with the
protocol there will be a response
and from from europe
they will probably start looking at
sections of the trade deal and it'll
it'll just make a total mess of
everything rather than have a negotiated
negotiated settlement and then you know
several ministers in the last 24 hour
secretaries of state including the
attorney general seem to be indicating
and they're not saying that definitively
but they seem to be indicating that the
british government
are prepared to unilaterally change the
protocol without consultation with the
irish government or europe and that
would just be an absolute mess i think
it would be a complete fiasco and
another betrayal of what was agreed let
me i don't know if you're a betting man
uh mr herm but if you were a betting man
or a soothsayer whatever you want to put
it nostradamus for a moment just go
forward 20 years how feasible could it
be
that there's by then a united ireland uh
the scotland has gone independent that
the uk
basically is left with england and wales
i mean is that something which actually
right now could be a realistic uh
situation in 20 years time
in 20 years time i think it could be i
think scotland will come up first again
uh particularly if scottish nationalist
party go in with labor after the next
election if they were to have enough
seats to form a government that's a big
if but it is a possibility
there will be um in that time scale uh
hopefully the work will be completed and
there will be a border poll it'll be up
to the people what they decide um but um
i think you know
from my point of view it should be on
the basis of consent and agreement the
one thing we don't need on the island of
ireland
is to go back into the troubled days so
it will be the ability of the
politicians over the next 20 years to
see if they can both do the preparatory
work and be able to negotiate and be
able to satisfy most of the unionists i
i don't think you'll ever get everybody
on board and nobody probably should
expect that but it it will be a
challenge but
i think what's what's more difficult
persons but
if if we can't resolve uh even the
protocol how will we ever resolve the
bigger issues that are down the road and
and this is really and the protocol by
the way i should say for your
your viewers is really what was brought
in negotiated between
europe and and boris johnson uh to avoid
a border a land border in ireland uh so
that we could um
northern ireland would stay in the
single market yeah and be able to get
investment be able to get jobs if he now
rips it up frankly it's another breach
of trust and that's the problem and i
think that that that in its way i think
the way boris johnson is going about
this is going to break trust so badly i
think it makes it more not less likely
that the uk ultimately fractures because
why would anyone trust him uh i've got
to leave it there i'm afraid uh bernier
brilliant to talk to you thank you so
much for coming on piers morgan and
simpson really appreciate it
thank you very much
thank you